hello everyone and
thank you for joining this session
focused on making business calls safer
and more effective with verified calls
my name is gal i'm a product manager at
google
and i'm joined by my teammate steve who
leads our partnerships
let me kick things off by sharing a
personal story
last month my band tried to call me
several times
about the potential fraudulent activity
on my account
but to be honest i just missed those
polls in the sea
of spam courses that i received every
day
i only realized that something was wrong
after a week when i tried to use my
credit card and it declined
now luckily i had a spirit card so no
a big damage was done but you can
imagine how stressful this situation
might have been
with slightly different circumstances
and
this story puts the spotlight on
the importance of effective
communication
over the phone between businesses and
consumers
so today i'll start off by sharing a
pain point we identified
in in those communications and now we
went
about developing a solution around it
and then i'll turn it to stephen
who will explain how we work with
leading partners
in order to solve this huge pain points
to as many users and
as many businesses as we can
when we look at the data we see that the
average person receives 30 spam calls
each month
and over 2019 there was a sizable
increase in phone calls
the vast majority of businesses feel
outbound calls are important for them to
meet their customer service goals
but here's the problem like me
most consumers simply don't answer their
phone if they don't recognize the number
so there's a massive gap in the
perceived importance
of polls and their actual effectiveness
which is low because people don't answer
so how do we reach this stage
today any device that is connected to
the internet
is capable of making voice calls through
voip
this means that the good old color id
system which displays the caller party
number
can be spoofed very easily there's no
trust in the system
so in practice the person that sits in
the other side of the world
can make a call to my phone and it will
look like
a similar as a call for my local a
bank number so why would consumers trust
uh phone calls anymore
this brings us to verified goals being
helpful and provide
a trust experiences to our users is that
correct what we do at google
and on the left of the screen you can
see our business call
looks today at best it's an unidentified
call
nothing personal it's just a phone
number it doesn't mean
anything to the user and it looks very
similar to
a spam call i receive or the bank call i
missed they look exactly the stem
next you'll see how a verified calls
look like
[Music]
so let's walk through the experience on
the top we got a blue badge
with a verified check mark and we also
display the name and logo of the brand
so the user can know who's calling
finally
we allow the user to state the reason
for calling
and think just think about how wonderful
would have it been if my band could show
hey
this is me calling and this is the
reason about a potential fault in your
account
i will obviously pick this phone call up
in a second
and as you can see we included all of
the information that consumers value in
order to make sure we set the ground up
for an engaging and productive
communication between the two
sides so
we call this product verified calls
so i want to let walk you through what
verified means
for one it signals that the business has
passed google's verification process
it also validates that the call is
coming from
a the number is shown in other words
it's not spoofed
and finally give the user the
information they need including the
reason for calling
so they can make an informed decision
let me walk you through the verification
process we use an
out-of-band channel to verify the calls
meaning that the phone call it still
goes through regular channels without
any change
and the verification is done separately
through an api
and to make it even easier for brands to
join we work with selected telephony
providers to integrate the api
and perform the verification and this
minimize the friction
for brands to join the first step is to
query
the api for reachability data and make
sure the phone number
can deliver a verified course experience
once this is done the next step is to
send google the brand phone number the
consumer phone number
and the call reason and google syncs
this information with the device
and once the voice call arrives the user
will see
the verified calls ui and now
i'm excited to share with you our demo
which you can see how easy it is to get
your calls verified
to verify a call the first step is to
check if the phone number is reachable
as you can see i received a response
that the
device is indeed reachable so i can
continue to the next step and send the
verified calls information
since i received the 200 response from
the server i know
my data was received and i can go ahead
and make a regular phone call
and the phone call will be verified
[Music]
without going into too many details i'll
just say that
our services are powered by the great
infrastructure of google cloud
and i will end my section by mentioning
that
we have designed this api with our
user's privacy in mind
and google removes any personal
information after the verification
is complete now i'm happy to turn this
over to steve that will show you how we
found
how we are partnering with businesses
and share the tremendous interest we
think
thanks gal as you recall from the
beginning of the presentation
87 of consumers don't answer calls from
unknown numbers
this is particularly a problem for
urgent calls like gao's case with this
bank
by verifying the caller with logo and
other details like call reason
our research shows we can make calls
more trustworthy
communicate the relevance to the user
and ultimately improve answer
for the launch of verify calls google
has partnered with leading providers
like the ones on this page
to make calls more trustworthy and
relevant for consumers
for the latest on all partners
supporting verified calls
please visit the website below
our focus on making business and
consumer communications more trustworthy
and engaging doesn't stop at voice calls
back in december 2019 we publicly
launched verified sms
similar to how verify calls enhances
calling experiences
verified sms makes business sms
messaging safer and more trustworthy
by adding sender verification and
branding
many brands like 1 800 flowers
kayak and google pay are already sending
messages with verified sms which is live
across nine countries
including us and canada and north
america brazil and mexico and south
america
uk spain and france and europe
and india and the philippines in asia
and we have more countries planned in
2020 for more information on this
service
please visit the link below
when we started down this path of
creating both verified sms and verified
calls we expected verified
communications to be valuable to both
businesses
and users in a recent user cinema survey
in the us and in brazil for verified sms
we tested this assumption and the
feedback was overwhelmingly positive
in that same survey we were both
positively surprised
to see how strong user sentiment was
across
the customer life cycle particularly
areas
that influence new and repeat business
like business consideration likelihood
to purchase
and likelihood to recommend while we
haven't conducted the same user
sentiment survey for verified calls
given how new it is
anecdotal evidence from partner
discussions give us confidence that
sentiment will be equally strong for the
service too
verified calls is first available in
these five countries
us mexico and brazil and the americas
spain and europe
and india and asia with more countries
planned in 2020
the google phone app and verify calls
comes pre-loaded
on many android devices in these markets
including ones from
motorola nokia xiaomi
one plus and of course pixel however if
you don't already have the google phone
app on your android phone that's okay
coming soon you'll be able to download
it from the play store
for partners and businesses wanting to
take advantage of verified calls
it's simple to get started just register
your interest
in the website or email us directly for
more information
thank you for joining galanite today to
hear how verified calls
makes business calls safer and more
purposeful have a great day